vertex form is this form here it's y
equals a times X minus H 2 the quantity
squared plus K H and K are the vertex
points ok so this is HK is the vertex ok
vertex is the point where the parabola
changes direction either like that or
like that so it's a high point of the
low point okay and then the a if it's
positive the parabola opens up if it's
negative it opens down and if a is
larger it's gonna stretch the parabola
making it narrower if it's smaller like
1/2 1/3 1/4 it's gonna make it wider so
it's going to compress it so this is the
basic form of the for the vertex form of
a quadratic or a parabola so in this
example you can see that each here is
negative 1 notice it's the opposite sign
this one the y-coordinate of the vertex
is positive 3 notice it's the same sign
so if we go to graph this the vertex is
going to be at negative 1 positive 3
okay there's the vertex notice that a
value is negative its opening down and
it's being stretched by 2 times so what
you can do if you want to get a good
graph here is just graph this parent
function right here
okay so just ignoring the 1 and the 3
for a moment and if we make a table
let's just pick some values like 0 1 2
so of course 0 is going to be 0 1
squared is 1 times negative 2 is
negative 2 2 squared is 4 times negative
2 is negative 8 and what we can do is
instead of graphing from the origin we
can graph from this vertex point here
so we're going to go right 1 and down 2
right 1 down 2 and we're going to go
right to down 8 so 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
right 2 down 8 now
parabolas their symmetric about the
vertex so you can reflect these points
over this axis of symmetry you're going
to have a point here and you're going to
have a point here and there's your graph
okay
so when I went right one down two you
can also go left one down two right two
down eight left two down eight okay or
you can just think about reflecting it
over this center line this axis of
symmetry so this has been the vertex
form of a quadratic I'll see you in the
next video